hello and welcome to the session on data
science my name is Mohan and today we
are going to take a look at what this
buzz is all about so what is the agenda
for today we will talk about what is the
need for data science and then what
exactly is data science some definitions
and also understand the differences
between data science and business
intelligence then we will talk about the
prerequisites for learning data science
and then what does the data scientist do
what are the activities performed by a
data scientist as a part of his daily
life and then we will talk about the
data science lifecycle with a quick
example and briefly touch upon the
demand or ever-increasing demand for
data scientist all right so let's get
started now you must have already heard
about autonomous cars so I'm sure you
must be excited to have a car driving by
itself which will take you from home to
office or office to home right and
that's where one of the examples where
data science is used and the car needs
to take a lot of decisions in this whole
process whether to speed up whether to
apply the brain take a left turn right
turn or slow down so all these decisions
are basically a part of data science and
there is a study that says that
self-driving cars will minimize
accidents and in fact it will root out
more than 2 million deaths caused by car
accidents annually self-driving cars
right now there's a lot of research and
there is a lot of testing going on and
not a lot of cars are yet in production
in terms of usage but it's going to
happen every automotive company what its
name is investing in self-driving cars
so in about 10 to 15 years some of the
studies say that most of the cars will
be autonomous or self-driving cars where
else there are issues for example if we
take air
this is another area where data science
contributes in a big major way flights
get delayed due to weather conditions
because the weather is not predicted in
time and the demand of passengers is not
probably seen ahead of time for all
these you need data science then this
could be improper route planning and
some customers might miss some flights
that again needs data science and
similarly it could be incorrect
decisions in selecting the right
equipment so which plane should fly in
which route that's the equipment it's
being mentioned here if that is not
planned properly and you might end up in
a situation where the plane is not
available it has you got turn for a
flight in a particular route so these
are some of the challenges can one of
the representative industries we are
talking about which is Airlines so if we
use data science properly all of these
or most of these problems can be avoided
and that will help in reducing the pain
both for the airlines and also for the
passengers a few more examples what else
can we do there are some of the other
things that we can do and we will stick
to the airline industry we can do better
route planning so that there are less
cancellations and less frustrated people
we can predict use predictive analytics
and predict any delays that are there so
that some sweats can be rescheduled
ahead of time and there are no
last-minute changes Dana science can
also be used to make promotional offers
and the last but not least is what kind
of planes should be used or the
different classes of planes that should
be used in different routes for better
performance so these are some examples
of how data science can be used in
Airlines and another example or on the
industry where data science can be used
and benefited would be in logistics so
companies like FedEx they use data
science models to increase
their efficiency drastically to optimize
the roads and cut costs and so on so
before their delivery truck actually
sets out they determine which is the
best possible route to ship their items
to the customers and based on various
inputs they also predict or come up with
the best suited time to deliver and last
but not least they determine what is the
best mode of transport for this delivery
as well so what is data science used for
these are some of the main areas where
data science is used of better
decision-making there are always tricky
decisions to be made so which is the
right decision which way to go so that
is one area then for predicting for
performing predictive analysis like for
example can we predict delays like in
the case of Airlines can we predict
demand for certain products let's say
any commerce that is the second area
third area is pattern discovery of
pattern recognition is there a pattern
in which people are buying items for
example it could be seasonality if you
take the data sales data for multiple
years there may be a pattern in a way
people are buying that that's a buying
pattern certain months probably the
sales will increase certain months of
sales will come down certain quarters
traditionally the sales will be higher
certain quarters so that is a pattern
and this pattern discovery is another
area where data science is applied so
what is data science now let's take an
example a real life example on a day to
day basis we use or we try to make some
decisions let's say we want to buy some
furniture online for our new office so
how do you go about doing this you need
to take a bunch of decisions to actually
do the purchase so we start with which
website which portal or which website
you should use so we try to find out
let's say you want to buy the furniture
obviously you don't go to a online
grocery store because you need furniture
because there are several websites so
that is the first decision you need to
take which website I should
use so once we have multiple websites
you kind of discard all the websites
which don't sell furniture and you stick
to those websites which sell furniture
now within that we try to find out what
is the ratings of this websites if the
ratings is more that means they are
reliable quality probably is good and so
on and so forth so only then you want to
buy from that particular website so
anything that doesn't satisfy this
criteria you close all those websites
close in the sense you close the browser
right so you still are left with maybe a
few of these which satisfy your criteria
that is which sell the pages or websites
that sell furniture they have a rating
of 4 and above and then you look for
discount is somebody providing discount
greater than 20% then again you filter
out some of them which probably are not
providing any discount and zero down to
one or two websites which are probably
providing those discounts and go ahead
and select the furniture and purchase it
so this is a very basic example probably
don't follow this always exactly the
same way but just to illustrate drive
home the point so we can answer a lot of
questions using data science for example
when we take a cab and we book a cab now
to go from location a to location B what
is the best route that the cab can take
to reach in the fastest way or in the
least amount of time there could be
several factors there could be traffic
there could be bad road there could be
weather now all these come as inputs and
a decision needs to be taken as to which
is the best route another example is TV
shows so Netflix and maybe even other a
lot of other TV channels they have to
perform this analysis to find out what
kind of shows people are viewing what
kind of shows people are liking and and
so on and so forth so that they can then
sell this info
to advertisers because their main source
of revenue is advertising so this is
again major function of data science
predictive maintenance we need to find
out will my car break down will my
refrigerator break down in the next year
or two years should I be prepared to buy
a new refrigerator you can potentially
apply data science here as well
then in politics a lot of data science
is applied in politics you must have
seen on TV about US elections or in UK
or even in India nowadays everybody is
applying data science in elections and
trying to capture the words or rather
the voters influence the waters
personalized messages providing
personalized messages and so on and so
forth and that is what not only that
people use data science to even predict
who is going to win the elections it's a
different matter that probably not all
predictions about to be true but then
yes this is they use data science to do
this predictions so what is the process
or what are the various steps in data
science the first step is asking the
right question and exploring the data
basically you want to know what exactly
is the problem you're trying to solve
so that is asking the right question so
that is the this circle out here then
the next step is after exploring the
data so is the first step you will ask
some questions what exactly is the
problem you're trying to solve and then
obviously you will have some data for
that as input and you perform some
exploratory analysis on the data for
example you need to clean the data to
make sure everything is fine and so on
and so forth so that all that is a part
of exploratory analysis and then you
need to do the modeling let's say if you
have to perform machine learning you
need to decide which algorithm to use
and which model to use and then you need
to train the model and so on and so
forth so that's all part of the modeling
process and then you run your data
through the
and then through this process and then
you come out with the final results of
this exercise which includes visualizing
the results and preparing a way to
communicate the results to the concerned
people so it could be in the form of
PowerPoint slides or it could be in the
form of a dashboard which is basically
what we call as a visualization and so
all the insights that have been gathered
through this exercise that has to be
communicated in a proper way in a
easy-to-understand way which is again a
a key part of this whole exercise
communicating the results so let's now
talk about the difference between
business intelligence and data science
now business intelligence was one of the
initial phases where people started
making God wanted to make some sense out
of data so for some of you who may not
be aware there were multiple phases of
this IT devolution so initially there
was all automations you had automation
of your selling process manufacturing
process you had your ERP systems your
CRM systems and and so on how which are
basically enterprise resource planning
and customer relationship management ERP
and CRM and all these enterprise
applications were generating a lot of
data so then people started saying that
ok we need to understand or get some
information out of this data so that's
how business intelligence started so if
we take from a data source perspective
let's compare these from with each of
these criteria the criteria are what
does the data source what is the method
what are the skills and what is the
focus and if we compare business
intelligence with data science deserve
it looks as far as the data source is
concerned business intelligence was
primarily using structured data so you
had all your enterprise applications
like ERP CRM and so on and they were
working out of pretty much our DBMS
relational database management systems
like Oracle M as
kill my school and so on so all this
data was structured in neat form form of
tables rows and columns and then they
were all brought in to a centralized
place because then it remember these
were still different applications so
they were working off different
databases in silos so if you wanted to
get a combined view you needed to create
what is known as a data warehouse and
bring all this data together and then
look at it in a uniform way so this is
what business intelligence was doing
pretty much it was structured data and
it had reports and dashboards that was
pretty much of what was there in
business intelligence now with data
science in addition to structured data
we also use a lot of unstructured data
example web logs or comments if we are
talking about customer feedback there is
a structured part there is an
unstructured part where people write
three text data signs includes that as
well and brings everything and then
performs analysis so data source wise
that is the difference methods in
business intelligence pretty much it is
analytical in the sense that okay you
have some data we are just trying to
present the truth and mostly what has
happened historical data that's it in
case of data science we go beyond that
we go deeper in terms of finding why a
certain behavior has occurred and also
go beyond just providing a report there
is a deeper statistical analysis that is
done that is what is the scientific part
and deeper insights are gathered not
just reporting so that's from a method
perspective I'm a skills perspective
business intelligence needs a little bit
of Statistics but more of visualization
because they primarily consisted of
dashboards are they primarily consist of
dashboards and reports whereas in data
science the visualization of course is
there but there is a lot more of
statistics involved because we are
looking at things like correlation we
are looking for example if we perform
machine learning we try to do regression
try to predict what will be the sales
maybe in the future and so on and so
forth so
it is much more involved in case of data
science compared to business
intelligence the skills are many more
compared to business intelligence and
last but not least what is the focus
focus of business intelligence is pretty
much historical data so the sales have
happened based on the sales still today
you try to come up with the report what
was my sales maybe for this whole year
or maybe for the last five years and so
on and so forth in data science you take
historical data but you also combine
that with maybe some other required
information and you also try to predict
the future so we try to extrapolate
maybe the sales and say ok sales as of
now as of today this is the sales is 5
million and if we based on the
historical information we see that sales
increase on our you don't know monthly
basis 10 percent that is what history
says so our sales for next month will be
this much right so that is the focus of
data science it goes beyond just
reporting so what are the prerequisites
for data science there are three
essential traits required for to be a
data scientist one is curiosity you need
to be able to ask questions the first
step in data science is asking question
what is the problem we are trying to
solve
if you ask the right question only then
you'll get the right answer very often
this is a very crucial step where a lot
of data science projects fail because
you're you may be asking the wrong
question and then obviously when you get
done so that's not down so you're
looking for so it is very important that
you ask the right question
needless to say then the second part or
the second trait is common sense so you
need to be creative you need to come up
with ways to use the data that you have
and try to solve the business problem on
hand in many cases you may not have all
the data that you need in many cases the
data may be incomplete so that is where
you need to come
with vase what are the best ways to fill
these gaps wherever this is missing and
that's where common sense comes into
play last but not least after doing all
this analysis if you are unable to
communicate the results in the right way
the whole exercise will fail so
communication is a key trait for a data
scientist maybe technically you may be a
genius but then if you are unable to
communicate those results in a proper
way once again that will not help so
these are the three main traits
curiosity common sense and communication
skills in a way you can say these are
the three C's okay so what are the other
prerequisites first one so machine
learning machine learning is the
backbone of data science data science
involves quite a bit of machine learning
in addition to the basic statistics that
we do so a data scientist needs to have
a good hang or need to be very good at
data science the second part is modeling
so modeling is also a part of machine
learning in a way but you need to be
good at identifying what are the
algorithms that are most suitable to
solve a given problem what models can be
used and how do we train these models
and so on and so forth so that is the
second component then statistics
statistics is like the core foundation
of data science so you need to
understand statistics and you need to
have a good hang of statistics in order
to be a good data scientist and this
will also help in getting good results
programming is to some extent required
at least some program or the other would
be required as a part of executing a
data science project the most common
programming languages are Python and are
Python specially is becoming a very
popular programming language in data
science because of its ease of learning
because of the multiple libraries that
it supports for performing data science
and
machine learning and so on so fightin is
by far one of the most popular languages
in data science if anyone of you is is
wanting to learn a new language that
should be bitin and then of course you
need to understand databases how
databases work how to handle databases
how to get data out of databases and so
on so these are some of the key
components of data science now coming to
the tools and skills that are used in
data science these are some of the
skills from a language perspective it is
Python or R and from a skills
perspective in addition to some of the
programming languages it would help if
you have a good knowledge or good
understanding of statistics and what are
the tools that are used in data analysis
SAS is one of the most popular tools
it's been there for very long time and
that's the reason it is very popular and
however this is compared to most of the
other tools it is a proprietary software
whereas Python and our mostly open
source the other tools are like Jupiter
Jupiter Nordberg's you have our studio
these are more development environments
and development tools so Jupiter
notebooks as a interactive development
environment similarly our studio is for
performing or writing our code and
performing analytics and performing data
analysis and machine learning activities
you can perform in our studio it has a
very nice UI and initially our was not
so popular primarily because it did not
have user interface and our studio is a
relatively new addition and after the
advent of our studio our became
extremely popular and there are other
tools like MATLAB and of course some
people do with Excel as well as far as
data warehousing is concerned some of
the skills that are required are ETL so
in order to extract data and transform
load et l stands for extract transform
load so you have data in databases like
your ERP system RAC
Grahame system you need to extract that
and then do some transformations and
then load it into your warehouse so that
all the data from various sources looks
uniform then you need some SQL skills
which is basically querying the data
writing SQL queries Hadoop is another
important skill especially if you are
handling large amounts of data and also
one of the specialities of Hadoop is it
can be used for handling unstructured
data as well so it can be used for large
amounts of structured and unstructured
data then spark is a excellent computing
engine for performing data analysis or
machine learning in a distributed mode
so if you have large amount of data
the combination of SPARC and Hadoop can
be extremely powerful
so you store your data in Hadoop HDFS
and use part as your computation engine
it works in a distributed mode similar
to hon do you like a cluster so that
those are excellent skills for data
warehousing and there are some standard
tools that are available like
informatica data stage talent and also
AWS redshift if you want to do some on
the cloud
I think AWS redshift is again a good
tool data visualization tools or data
visualization some of the skills that
would be required
are let's say R u R provides some very
good visualization capabilities
especially for developing during
development and then you have Python
libraries matplotlib and so on which
provides very powerful visualization
capabilities and that is from skills
perspective
whereas tools that can be used are
tableau is a very very popular
visualization tool again that's a
proprietary tool so it's a little
expensive maybe but excellent
capabilities from a visualization
perspective then there are tools like
Cognos which is an IBM product which
provides very good visualization
capabilities as well and then coming to
the machine learning part of it the
skills required there are Python which
is more for programming part and then
you will need some mathematical skills
like algebra linear algebra specially
and then statistics and maybe a little
bit of calculus and so on
and the tools that are used for machine
learning are spark ml lib and Apache
mahout and one cloud if you want to do
something you can use Microsoft Azure ml
studio as well so these are by no means
an exhaustive list there are actually
many many tools and probably a few more
skills also may be there but this is
discuss a quick overview like a
summarizing of summarization of the
tools and skills now moving on to the
life of a data scientist what does a
data scientist - during the course of
his work so let's see so typically a
data scientist is given a problem a
business problem that he needs to solve
and in order to do that if you remember
from the previous slide he basically
asks the question as to what is the
problem that he needs to solve so that
is the first thing he has got the
problem and the next thing is to gather
the data that is required to solve this
problem so he goes about looking for
data from anywhere it could be the
enterprise very often the data is not
provided in the nice format that he
would like to have it or we would like
to have it so first step is to get
whatever data that is possible what is
known as raw data in whatever format so
it could be enterprise data it could be
it is there probably a requirement to go
and get some public data in some cases
so all the raw data is collected and
then that is processed and analyzed and
in prepared into a format in which it
can be used and then it is fed into the
analytic system be it a machine learning
algorithm or a statistical model and we
get the output and then he puts these
output in a proper format for presenting
it to the stakeholders and communicating
those insights or the results to the
stakeholders so this is a very
high-level view of like a a day in the
life of data scientists gathering data
raw data performing some quick analysis
on that and maybe processing or
manipulating this data to
it into a certain good format so that it
can be used for the analysis feeding
this into that analysis system that has
been designed be it mathematical models
machine learning models and then get the
results the insights and then present it
in a nice way so that the stakeholders
can understand how about machine
learning algorithms so let's see what
are the various machine learning
algorithms that would be required for a
data scientist so these are a few of the
algorithms again there's not an
exhaustive list
we have regression is one of the
supervised learning models or techniques
so in case of regression you try to
let's say come up with a continuous
number so the difference between
regression and let's say a
classification is that in case of
classification those are discrete values
whereas here we are talking about
regression where you I'd say you are
trying to predict the temperature which
is a continuous value or the share price
which is a continuous value so that is
regression so you need to know what is
regression how to perform regression and
we need to understand clustering so
clustering is one of the unsupervised
learning techniques in this case there
is no label data that is available and
you get some data and then you want to
put this into some shape so that you can
analyze it and you try to make sense out
of it let's say you have one example as
you have a list of cricketers and they
have not been marked as bowlers and
batsman nor all-rounders or whatever so
you just have their names and maybe how
many runs they scored how many wickets
they have taken and so on but there is
no readily available information saying
that okay this person is a batsman this
person is a bowler and so on so I'm
talking about cricket hopefully most of
you are familiar with the game of
cricket so how do we find out so then we
put this into a clustering mechanism and
then the system will say that okay these
are the people who are all who have all
scored good amount of
so they belong to one cluster these are
all the people who have taken good
amount of wickets so they belong to one
cluster and maybe here are some people
who have taken good amount of wickets
and they have made good amount of runs
so they maybe belonging to one group and
then we take a look at it and then we
label them as okay people who have all
together and those were you know
scored many runs they are we label them
as batsmen people who have taken a lot
of wickets we label them as bowlers and
people who have taken good amount of
wickets and also made some good runs we
label them as all runners but the system
will just say okay this is cluster one
cluster two cluster three the names we
give be human beings have to give the
names no decision tree is used for what
is known as classification primarily it
can also be used for regression but by
and large it is used for classification
and here again it's a very logical way
in which the algorithm goes about
classifying the various inputs one of
the biggest advantages of decision tree
is that it's very easy to understand and
it's very easy to explain why a certain
object has been classified in a certain
way compared to maybe some of the other
mechanisms like say support vector
machines or logistic regression and so
on so that's the advantage of decision
tree but that is also very popular
algorithm then we have support vector
machines primarily for classification
purpose and then we have knife base this
is a pain a statistical probability
based classification method so these are
a few algorithms there are a few more
and that are not listed here but there
are some more algorithms as well and by
the way there are more detailed or there
are detailed videos about each of these
algorithms available you can check in
the playlist so now let's talk about the
life cycle of a data science project
okay the first step is the concept study
in this step it involves understanding
the business problem asking questions
get a good understanding of the business
model meet up with all the stakeholders
understand what kind of data is
available and all that is a part of the
first step so here are a few examples we
want to see what are the various
specifications and then what is the end
goal what is the budget is there an
example of this kind of a problem that
has been maybe solved earlier so all
this is a part of the concept study and
another example could be a very specific
one to predict the price of a 1.25 carat
diamond and there may be relevant
information inputs that are available
and we want to predict the price the
next step in this process is data
preparation data gathering and data
preparation also known as data munging
or sometimes it is also known as data
manipulation so what happens here is the
raw data that is available may not be
usable in its current format for various
reasons so that is why in this step a
data scientist would explore the data he
will take a look at some sample data if
we pick there are millions of Records
pick a few thousand records and see how
the data is looking are there any gaps
is the structure appropriate to be fed
into the system are there some columns
which are probably not adding value may
not be required for the analysis very
often these are like names of the
customers they will probably not add any
value or much value from an analysis
perspective the structure of the data
may be the data is coming from multiple
data sources and the structures may not
be matching what are the other problems
there may be gaps in the data so the
data all the columns all the cells are
not filled if you're talking about
structured data
there are several blank records or blank
columns so if you use that data directly
you'll get errors or you'll get
inaccurate results so how do you either
get rid of the data or how do you fill
those gaps with something meaningful so
all that is a part of data munging or
data manipulation so these are some
additional sub topics within that so it
integration is one of them there are any
conflicts in the data there may be data
may be redundant dia data resident
redundancy is another issue there may be
you have let's say data coming from two
different systems and both of them have
customer table for example customer
information so when you merge them there
is a duplication issue so how do we
resolve it so that is what data
transformation as I said there will be
situations where data is coming from
multiple sources and then when we merge
them together they may not be matching
so we need to do some transformations to
make sure everything is similar we may
have to do some data reduction if the
data size is too big you may have to
come up with ways to reduce it
meaningfully without losing information
then data cleaning so there will be the
wrong values or use null values or the
missing values so how do you handle all
of that a few examples of very specific
stuff so there are missing values how do
you handle missing values or null values
here in this particular slide we have
seen three types of issues one is
missing value then you have null value
you see the difference between the two
right so in the missing value there is
nothing blind null value it says null no
system cannot handle if there are null
values similarly there is improper data
so it's supposed to be numeric value but
there is a string or a non numeric value
so how do we clean and prepare the data
so that our system can work flawlessly
so there are multiple ways and there is
no one common way of doing this it can
vary from project to project it can vary
from what exactly is the problem we are
trying to solve it can vary from data
scientist to data scientist organization
to organization so these are like some
standard practices people come up with
and and of course there will be a lot of
trial and error somebody would have
tried out something and it worked and
we'll continue to use that mechanism so
that's how we need to take care of data
cleaning now what are the various ways
of doing you know if values are missing
how do you take care of that now if the
data is too large and only a few Records
have some missing values then it is okay
to just get
of those entire rows for example so if
you have a million records and out of
which 100 records don't have full data
so there are some missing values in
about 100 records so it's absolutely
fine because it's a small percentage of
the data so you can get rid of the
entire records which are missing values
but that's not a very common situation
very often you will have multiple or at
least a large number of data set for
example out of million records you may
have 50,000 records which are like
having missing values now that's a
significant amount you cannot get rid of
all those records your analysis will be
inaccurate so how do you handle such
situation so there are again multiple
ways of doing it one is you can probably
four particular values are missing in a
particular column you can probably take
the mean value for that particular
column and fill all the missing values
with the mean value so that first of all
you don't get errors because of missing
values and second you don't get results
that are way off because these values
are completely different from what is
there so that is one way then a few
other could be either taken the median
value or depending on what kind of data
we are talking so something meaningful
we will have put in there if we are
doing some machine learning activity
then obviously as a part of data
preparation you need to split the data
into training and test data set the
reason being if you try to test with a
data set which the system has already
seen as a part of training then it will
tend to give reasonably accurate results
because it has already seen that data
and that is not a good measure of the
accuracy of the system so typically you
take the entire data set the input data
set and split it into two parts and
again the ratio can vary from person to
person individual preferences some
people like to split it into 50/50 some
people like it has 63 0.33 and 33.3 is
basically 2/3 and 1/3 and some people do
it as 8020 80 for training and 20 for
testing so you split the data perform
the training with the 80%
and then use the remaining 20% for
testing all right so that is one more
data preparation activity that needs to
be done before you start analyzing or
applying the data or putting the data
through the model then the next step is
model planning now this models can be
statistical models this could be machine
learning models so you need to decide
what kind of models you are going to use
again it depends on what is the problem
you're trying to solve if it is a
regression problem you need to think of
a regression algorithm and come up with
a regression model so it could be linear
regression or if you are talking about
classification then you need to pick an
appropriate classification algorithm
like logistic regression or decision
tree or SVM and then you need to train
that particular model so that is the
model building or model planning process
and the cleaned-up data has to be fed
into the model and apart from cleaning
you may also have to in order to
determine what kind of model you will
use you have to perform some exploratory
data analysis to understand the
relationship between the various
variables and see if the data is
appropriate and so on so that is the
additional preparatory step that needs
to be done so little bit of details
about exploratory data analysis so what
exactly is exploratory data analysis is
basically - as the name suggests you're
just exploring you just received the
data and you're trying to explore and
find out what are the data types and
what is the is the data clean in in each
of the columns what is the maximum
minimum value so for example there are
out-of-the-box functionality available
in tools like R so if you just ask for a
summary of the table it will tell you
for each column it will give some
details as to what is the mean value
what is the maximum value and so on and
so forth so this exercise or this
exploratory analysis is to get an
understanding of your data and then you
can take steps to during this process
you find there are a lot of me
values you need to take steps to fix
those you will also get an idea about
what kind of model to be used and so on
and so forth what are the various
techniques used for exploratory data
analysis typically these would be
visualization techniques like you use
histograms you can use box plots you can
use cata plots so these are very quick
ways of identifying the patterns or few
of the trends of the data and so on and
then once your data is ready you you
decided on the model what kind of model
what kind of algorithm you're going to
use if you are trying to do machine
learning you need to pass your 80% the
training data or rather you use that
training data to train your model and
the training process itself is iterative
so the training process you may have to
perform multiple times and once the
training is done and you feel it is
giving good accuracy then you move on to
test so you take the remaining twenty
percent of the data
remember we split the data into training
and test so the test data is now used to
check the accuracy or how well our model
is performing and if there are further
issues let's say model is still during
testing of the accuracy is not good then
you may want to retrain your model or
use a different models so this whole
thing again can be hydrated but if the
test process is past or it model passes
the test then it can go into production
and it will be deployed all right so
what are the various tools that we use
for model planning are is an excellent
tool a lot of ways whether you're doing
regular statistical analysis or machine
learning or any of these activities are
in along with our studio provides a very
powerful environment to do analysis
including visualization it has a very
good integrated realization of plot
mechanism which can be used for doing
exploratory data analysis and then later
on to do analysis detail analysis and
machine
and so forth then of course you can
write Python programs item offers rich
library for performing data analysis and
machine learning and so on MATLAB is a
very popular tool as well especially
during education so this is a very easy
to learn tool so MATLAB is another tool
that can be used and then last but not
least sass asses again very powerful it
is proprietary tool and it has all the
components that are required to perform
very good statistical analysis or
perform data science so those are the
various tools that will be required for
audit that can be used for model
building and so the next step is model
building so we have done the planning
part we said ok what is the algorithm
you're going to use what kind of model
we are going to use now we need to
actually train this model or build the
model rather so that it can then be
deployed so what are the various ways of
what are the various types of model
building activities so it could be let's
say in this particular example that we
have taken you want to find out the
price of one point three five carat
diamond so this is let's say a linear
regression problem you have data for
various carats of diamond and you use
that information you pass it through a
linear regression model or you create a
real linear regression model which can
then predict your price for 1.35 carat
so this is one example of model building
and then little bit details of how
linear regression works so linear
regression is basically coming up with a
relation between an independent variable
and a dependent variable so it is pretty
much like coming up with equation of a
straight line which is the best fit for
the given data so like for example here
y is equal to MX plus C so Y is the
dependent variable and X is the
independent variable we need to
determine the values of m and C for our
given data so that is what the training
process of
this model does at the end of the
training process you have a certain
value of M and C and that is used for
predicting the values of any new data
that comes all right so the way it works
is we use the training and the test data
set to train the model and then validate
whether the model is working fine or not
using test data and if it is working
fine then it is taken to the next level
which is put in production if not the
model has to be reaching if the QA c is
not good enough then the model is
retrained maybe with more data or you
come up with a newer model or algorithm
and then repeat the process so it is an
iterative process once the training is
completed training and test in this
model is deployed and we can use this
particular model to determine what is
the price of one point three five carat
diamond remember that was our problem
statement so now that we have the best
fit for this given data we have the
price of one point three five carat
diamond which is ten thousand so this is
one example of how this whole process
works now how do we build the model
there are multiple ways you can use
Python for example and use libraries
like Andersen pi to build a model
implemented this will be available as a
separate tutorial a separate video in
this playlist so stay tuned for that
moving on once we have the results the
next step is to communicate this results
to the appropriate stakeholders so which
is basically taking this results and
preparing like a presentation or a
dashboard and communicating these
results to the concern people so
finishing or getting the results of the
analysis is not the last step but you
need to as a data scientist take these
results and present it to the team that
has given you this problem in the first
place and explain your findings explain
the findings of this exercise and
recommend maybe what steps they need to
eight in order to overcome this problem
or solve this problem so that is the
pretty much once that is accepted and
the last step is to operationalize so if
everything is fine your data scientists
presentations are accepted then they put
it into factors and thereby they will be
able to improve or solve the problem
that they stated in step one okay so
quick summary of the life cycle you have
a concept study which is basically
understanding the problem asking the
right questions
and trying to see if there is enough
data to solve this problem and then even
maybe gather the data then data
preparation the raw data needs to be
manipulated you need to do data munging
so that you have the data in a certain
proper format to be used by the model or
our analytics system and then you need
to do the model planning what kind of a
model what algorithm you will use for a
given problem and then the model
building so the exact execution of that
model
it happens in step four and you
implement and execute that model and put
the data through the analysis in this
step and then you get the results this
results are then communicated packaged
and presented and communicated to the
stakeholders and once that is accepted
that is operationalized so that is the
final step now in the end let's take a
quick look at the demand for data
scientists data science is an area of
great demand the demand for data
scientists is currently huge and the
supply is very low so there is a huge
gap so what are some of the industries
with high demand for data scientists I
think gaming is definitely one area
where it's a industry which is consumer
facing industry and a lot of people play
games and growing industry and it
requires a lot of data science so that
is an area where data scientists and are
in demand then we have healthcare for
example data science is used for
diagnosis and several other activities
within healthcare predicting for example
so health care is definitely financed
definitely banks insurance companies all
of these there is a huge demand for data
scientists marketing is like a
horizontal functionality across all
industries there's a demand for data
scientist there then of course in
technology area so pretty much all of
these areas there is a lot of demand
globally there is a huge demand so this
is a very very critical skill that would
be required currently as well as in the
future
so let's summarize what we have seen so
far we talked about the need for data
science where data science can do and
what is data science and what are the
prerequisites of data science in terms
of the skills and programming languages
tools and so on and so forth we also
talked about the various tools that are
available like Python and R and we did a
comparison also between business
intelligence and data science and we did
a detailed discussion about the
lifecycle of a data science project with
an example and last but not least we
talked about the demand for data
scientists the global demand there's a
huge demand for data scientists we
talked about that as well so with that
we come to the end of this session thank
you very much for watching this video
and if there are any feedback any
comments please or any questions please
put it below and we will get back to you
provide your contact information or
email so that we can respond to you and
thank you very much once again and have
a good day bye bye
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here